>>> OVER THE WEEKEND, WHILE
MARTIN LUTHER KING III WAS IN
ARIZONA RALLYING TO EXPAND
VOTING RIGHTS, DONALD TRUMP WAS
THE SAME DAY IN THE SAME STATE
DOING THE EXACT OPPOSITE,
CONTINUING TO PUSH HIS BIG LIE.
>> LAST YEAR WE HAD A RIGGED
ELECTION AND THE PROOF IS ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE BIG
LIE.
THEY'RE THE BIG LIE.
>> THERE IS A REASON TRUMP WAS
IN ARIZONA, TO PUSH THE
LEGISLATURE TO DISINFRANCHISE
THE STATE'S VOTERS BASED ON ALL
OF THESE DERANGED ELECTION LIES.
>> HOPEFULLY YOUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND STATE LEGISLATORS
WILL BE SMART AND FAIR AND
DECISIVE AND LET THE WORLD KNOW
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED IN
ARIZONA.
>> STEVE BANNON SAID THIS IS
PART OF A NATIONWIDE EFFORT TO
HURT BIDEN GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
>> DECERTIFY BIDEN ELECTORS IN
ARIZONA, IN WISCONSIN, IN THE
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA, IN
THE GREAT STATE OF GEORGIA,
THOSE GREAT STATES WE WILL
DECERTIFY THOSE ELECTORS.
>> OF COURSE, THERE'S NO
CONSTITUTIONAL WAY TO DO THAT.
AND TRUMP DELIVERED THIS MESSAGE
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
PAY ATTENTION TO THIS PART --
>> WE HAVE TO BE A LOT SHARPER
NEXT TIME WHEN IT COMES TO
COUNTING THE VOTE.
THERE'S A FAMOUS STATEMENT,
SOMETIMES THE VOTE COUNT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE CANDIDATE AND
WE CAN'T LET THAT EVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO GET TOUGHER AND
SMARTER.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE VERY FOCUSED
RIGHT NOW ON CAPITOL HILL ABOUT
BEATING BACK REPUBLICAN EFFORTS
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT MAKE IT
TOUGHER TO VOTE.
WHILE IT'S TRUE MANY OF THOSE
EFFORTS ARE PREDICATED ON
TRUMP'S BIG LIE, THE FOCUS OF
THE SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY WE ALL
WITNESSED WAS MORE FOCUSED ON
THE COUNTING, NOT THE CASTING,
OF THE VOTES.
BECAUSE WHEN TRUMP SAYS, QUOTE,
WE HAVE TO BE A LOT SHARPER THE
NEXT TIME WHEN IT COMES TO
COUNTING THE VOTE, UNQUOTE, IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR HE MEANS STOP
COUNTING THE VOTES WHEN HE'S UP
AND WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE ON THE
LEAD, VOTE COUNTERS NEED TO FIND
VOTES FOR HIM, AS HE INSTRUCTED
GEORGIA REPUBLICAN SECRETARY OF
STATE BRAD RAFFENSPERGER TO DO.
>> THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
SAYING THAT YOU'VE RECALCULATED.
I JUST WANT TO FIND 11,780
VOTES, WHICH IS ONE MORE THAN WE
HAVE.
>> THIS PLAN TO PUT LOYALISTS IN
KEY POSITIONS WHERE THEY CAN DO
THIS FOR HIM IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW WITH TRUMP-BACKED CANDIDATES
FOR GOVERNOR, SECRETARY OF
STATE, AND MORE IN KEY STATES.
AND THERE ARE ALSO MORE ORGANIC,
LOWER LEVEL EFFORTS AS WELL FOR
ADHERENCE TO THE BIG LIE TO SLIP
INTO KEY POSTS.
EDWARD MECHANIC LANTOS OF
LANCASTER COUNTY, PENNSYLVANIA,
WAS RUNNING FOR LOCAL JUDGE
UNTIL HIS CAMPAIGN HIT A SNAG,
CHARGED WITH FOUR OFFENSES ON
HIS ROLE ON THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL JANUARY 6th.
IN PENNSYLVANIA RALLY ATTENDEE
WHO HAS NOT BEEN CHARGED WITH A
CRIME WON HIS RACE TO BE THE
MOUNT JOY TOWNSHIP JUDGE OF
ELECTIONS.
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO, REPUBLICAN
OF FLORIDA A FEW DAYS AGO,
CONDEMNED JANUARY 6th AS A
TERRIBLE THING THAT NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED BUT ALSO SUGGESTED
THE ANNIVERSARY WAS GETTING TOO
MUCH ATTENTION AND SEEMED TO
DOWNPLAY ITS SERIOUSNESS.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CONVINCE
MOST NORMAL AND SANE PEOPLE THAT
OUR GOVERNMENT LAST YEAR WAS
ALMOST THROWN BY A GUY WEARING A
VIKING HAT AND SPEEDOS.
>> THE SENATOR IS CORRECT OUR
GOVERNMENT WAS NOT ALMOST
OVERTHROWN BY I GUY WEARING A
VIKING HAT AND SPEEDOS BUT BY
ARMED MILITARY CONSPIRACISTS AND
OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
SEEKING TO INVALIDATE ELECTION
RESULTS BASED ON THE WIDE LIES
OF UNHINGED TEAM OF CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND BY MAGA MEDIA THAT
SPREAD THOSE LIES AND ABOUT MORE
THAN 140 HOUSE AND SENATE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO
DISENFRANCHISE ALL OF THE VOTERS
OF PENNSYLVANIA AND ARIZONA.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE
CONSPIRACY COULD HAVE WORKED AND
MIGHT WORK NEXT TIME.
PAY ATTENTION